[Music]
we're starting this episode out with a
question that we are never going to have
a good answer for
how many cells do animals have
i can already hear smee scoffing some
version of why is hank green asking me
such an obviously unanswerable question
while a rotifer chills out on my screen
and you're not wrong to be skeptical
there are a lot of animals in the world
and a lot of cells inside those animals
how could one ever hope to count all of
the cells in each of those animals and
how could we even begin
to assume that the amount of cells in
one individual is going to be the same
for all the other individuals and what
even would be the point of treating
every animal like a jar full of jelly
beans that we need to guess the number
of
are you waiting for the twist because
you know there's going to be a twist
maybe you even know what the twist is
already maybe you remember our video on
rotifers all the way back in 2019 where
we said
this
rotifers are utellic which means that
from the moment they are born
they will have a fixed number of cells
in their bodies for the rest of their
life for most rotifers that number is
around a thousand cells and for the
rotifer to grow
the cells themselves
which cannot divide have to get bigger
think about that for a second
we know how many cells are inside of a
rotifer which means that at some point
in history someone sat down and counted
the cells in a rotifer and they didn't
just stop at one rotifer they kept
counting going from rotifer to rotifer
to rotifer until a simple truth appeared
all of these rotifers had the same
number of cells as each other
so the rotifer is one of the few animals
that we can treat like a jar full of
countable beans and it is because of
this property called utility
the number of cells in the rotifer has
been set which means that if you're
looking at a mature rotifer you know
that you are looking at about a thousand
cells in action
it may be a little more or a little less
depending on the species but within
those species
all the individuals will be the same in
this one
very countable way
now we had hoped at this point that
maybe we could give you a fun exercise
in historical imagination we would ask
you something like what kind of person
would have the patience to count all of
the cells in a rotifer and then we would
give you the name of the scientist who
did the counting and maybe even quote
their writings on the subject however
science has many dark pasts that weave
through history binding together our
understanding of even the smallest
creatures with the political and social
forces that shape humanity
the word utility was brought into the
biological vernacular because of a
zoologist named eric martini who in the
beginning of the 20th century counted
the cells in the rotifer species
hidatina centa and established the
female individual had
958 somatic cells meaning all of the
cells apart from the individual's eggs
however we have to add that in addition
to martini's contributions to our
understanding of utility his legacy also
involves a debate between historians
over whether he engineered a nazi plot
to spread malaria among italian citizens
in 1943
which would be considered an act of
biological warfare martini was not the
first nor was he the last person to be
associated with both important
scientific discovery
and nazism
and while we could explore the question
of how many cells are inside animals
without making reference to him we think
that it's important not to gloss over
the ugliness that often accompanies the
history of science
other scientists were also fascinated by
utility in 1932 the scientist harvey j
van cleeve published his paper utility
or cell constancy in its relation to
body size confirming the cell counts
that martini had made in his rotifer
studies while also describing evidence
researchers had found for utility in
animals like gastrotricks and nematodes
and other scientists would add
tardigrades to that list
every animal begins its life as a single
cell that is full of destiny it divides
and divides and divides sending cells
tumbling down a path toward their fate
as they take on specific shapes and
functions that have been preordained
through a combination of chemical and
genetic cues
in most animals including our own many
of those cells continue to divide
whether that's to help us grow or heal
or adapt so while scientists have
estimated that humans have around
37.2 trillion cells their estimate is by
necessity based on very restrictive
assumptions about what a human body
looks like
ultimately most of us will exist
somewhere in a gray area of variation
around that number some of us will have
more some of us will have less whether
there's a deeper pattern underlying the
disparities is hard to pin down except
for the fact that the heart of nature is
diversity but not for the rotifer sure
it started with an egg that divided and
made more cells that followed a set path
to their final fate eventually growing
into the mature wheeled animals that we
love to watch but when the rotifer
reaches maturity it no longer makes any
new cells if it needs to grow
then the cells will grow but they will
not make new cells
and perhaps not needing to divide and
make new cells creates a sort of
peaceful constancy that means the
rotifer doesn't need to waste energy on
making new dna and duplicating its cells
but it also means that if the rotifer
gets hurt it does not have the tools to
make new cells to heal itself
we don't really have any idea why
rotifers or any other animal would
become utalic there's no obvious
phylogenetic relationship that exists
between utelic animals that we know of
and at times identifying utility in one
species has led us to make incorrect
assumptions about their relatives that's
because utility itself is a diverse
phenomenon some of those animals that we
mentioned were utilic it turns out they
are but also they aren't
tardigrades for example have storage
cells that help distribute energy but
that also sometimes divide to make more
storage cells and some gastrotricks have
even been documented healing themselves
after an injury
these may be cases of partial utility
while some parts of the animal do
maintain some kind of constancy while
others do not or it may be that even
within a phylum the occurrence of
utility has no obvious logic to it maybe
some gastro tricks are utalic and some
aren't
and as we said those kinds of cases just
add to the confusion of utility
the nematode cenorabiditis elegans has
been such a popular model organism in
part because we know that the adult c
elegans hermaphrodite has a body built
out of 959
somatic cells and knowing the path from
egg to embryo to juvenile to adult
through the story of those
959 somatic cells has been a tremendous
gift to science it's a blueprint of the
worm's development a pattern that
scientists can prove and disrupt to
uncover other hidden motifs
but it turns out that c elegans utility
is not the shared trait it was once
thought to be among nematodes
free-living marine nematodes were found
not to have it and other species have
been found whose skin is dotted with a
different number of nuclei revealing
variation where previous scientists had
not expected any and so
even in these unusual cases where it
seems like maybe we can get closer to
quantifying the number of cells in an
animal the simple act of counting paints
a much more complicated picture of our
world
nature
loves to change
even if that is a change towards a
bizarre case of constancy
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to all of the people whose
names are on the screen right now they
are our patrons they in a way
are like the individual cells that make
up the body of
journey to the microcosmosis
funding look there are a bunch of people
who decided that they want content like
this to exist on the internet and in
order to make sure it happens they
support us at patreon.com
journey2micro which you can find a link
to in the description check it out see
if you would like to join them
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]